hello everyone and welcome back to the
pork champs we are covering the second
game of the semi-final match between box
box and void boy and boy boy won the
first game so now box box needs to
retaliate in order to force a tiebreaker
game so without further ado let's check
it out box box opens with E 4 and we
have D 6 from void boy he goes for the
pivot defense and now Knight to c3
we have Knight to f6 and g3 now this is
the setup like we mentioned in the
previous video where a box box had two
white pieces he always goes for this
setup pretty much regardless of what a
black plays so here we have e 5
expanding in the center and the Bishop
to g2 we have g6 Virgo also once the
fiend head of his dark square Bishop and
Knight g2e - now preparing castles and
the knife from e2 will do nicely to
support to the DF for pawn push so the
shop g7 and both players castle now we
have castles castles and d3 now opening
up the dark square bishop so maybe the
Bishop to g5 will be an idea next and
this is actually played quite a lot c6
is the main idea here but here Webber
goes for h6 he takes away the g5 Square
from from vault box bishop and it is
already as a move 7 that we have a
completely new game so box box continues
with his plan we have f4 the striking
against the center and we have eight
captures on f4 we have G characters on
f4 now
the knight could also character also the
bishop could capture however box box
doesn't mind opening up his King a
little bit as he wants to continue
pushing those points and attacking so
Bishop to g4 and now comes h3 and now
this was a very interesting and also a
very tricky move because now now you're
basically forcing the bishop to go back
if you don't do that if you play
something else like a bunch of to h5
which is what boy boy did you allow
white to go for this double attack with
E 5 and now the knight is stacked and
also the b7 point is under attack so
here we have Knight back to h7 by voyboy
and the now comes the bishop character
ascend b7 so here white will win the
exchange we at Knight to d7 and best of
character Sonny
with Queen captures and white is now up
the exchange but his king is a little
bit wide open and with the queen
controlling this diagonal and this
bishop nicely controlling this one white
is missing the jeep on black does have
some compensation for the sacrificed
exchange so here
d4 is definitely the way to go you want
to add more defense to the e5 pawn
however box box decides to sacrifice
this pawn and go for development and
sort of an attack so Bishop to e3 he
gives up the e5 pawn D captures I mean
five and now Queen to d2 so here what we
trades on f4 we have characters captures
and now it doesn't make sense you want
to grab this Bishop here a force block
to capture and then eliminated the h6
bone as well and kind of completely open
up the black King however here whatever
finds the excellent Bishop to f3 and the
bishop is very safe there the Queen is
guarding it and you also might have some
ideas in the future maybe going Bishop
to h1 fall by Queen to g2 if possible so
rook to f2 our box box adds more
protection to the g2 Square and also
prepares the rook a to f1 to add more
more rooks into the attack so g5 whoa
boy now starts expanding and the King
set as well g5 is coming f5 and so on so
Knight F the e2 and here comes f5 so
that's a very nice expansion on the
Kings side however rook 8 f1 just bring
another rook into the game now
threatening to just pick up this bishop
so brush up the h1 just getting the
bishop out of harm's way and if this
rook for example ever moves then Queen
to g2 will be checkmate
so Bishop to b4 Vox box is still up
material so it's natural that he wants
to trade pieces we have f4 Webber
continues pushing and now Bishop
captures on g7 definitely the way to go
we have King captures and now Knight the
d4 might not be a terrible idea with the
idea of jumping to e6 that the black
King might have some problems there
however we have Knight to e4 box box who
goes for a different idea he cuts off
the Queen's defense of the bishop here
and plans on winning the bishop on the
next move
so for boys next move is pretty much
forced he has to go for Bishop captures
on e4 we have BK
actors on e4 and now Knight d2 f6 the
knight is under attack Sabu moves it it
might be a little bit better to go this
Knight to f6 as well simply to activate
this night and this night is now
defended you can bring it to e5 and so
on by playing this Knight to f6 you can
force this knife to stay here and now
box box does something that's not not
considered to be well the strongest he
should go for something like Queen to c3
pinned at night and then try to exploit
ideas like if I bring the knight into
the game and maybe move the rook rooks
away from the f5 maybe to the e-file or
the D file in the future or maybe even
to the g5 fouled by h4 something like
that however he plays the ephod right
away and it doesn't make sense but also
doesn't because you attack the defender
of the d7 square you want to go Queen to
d7 check the problem is Knights the e4
comes with a double attack on both the
Queen and the rook so here he does get
his Queen to d7 check but now rook to f7
and now both the Queen and the rook here
are under attack and what you probably
sorry that was a small slip what you
should do here is bring the Queen back
give give back your exchange with Knight
captures rook captures and then the game
continues with the material on the board
being exactly equal however the Box box
said okay since you sacrificed your
queen in the previous game I will now
sacrifice my queen in this one and he
goes for east six and it's not a very
convincing move since it's not all that
clear how you will continue this so
Volvo just captures it wrote characters
on b7 we have a cat person d7 and now he
also wins one of the rooks with Knight
captures so King captures and now we see
box box idea he wants to play rook to d1
defend his pawn somehow get this night
over to c6 let's say or east six and
from there the night will be able to
also guard the da square so that's
that's the plan so cold way immediately
covers the d8 square blocks the pawn and
now of course attacks the d7 phone so
look the d1 attacking the d7 pawn and
now Knight to f6 and here it becomes
clear
that the d7 point will not you will not
be able to defend it like I said if you
could somehow bring your knight over
here then it'd be great but for the
moment you can or rather box box tri-c
goes Knight to the b4 with the threat of
just 96 Jeff for example if Knight
captures this we'll pick up the Queen
however a worker just goes Queen
captures only four and now the problem
is well now you can't really move the
night because the rook is hanging here
so box box tried one more last resort
trick to try and we'll throw our office
guard with Knight to f5 check now if the
King moves you can just pick up the
Queen however Webber just captured an f5
and now it's a queen and night against
the rook so it was in this position I
move 31 that box box resigned the game
and avoid boy wins their semi-final
match which means that voyboy goes into
the finals where he will play against
the mighty hutch and also for your
entertainment I found a nice clash in
the top lane between the void boring box
box that really kind of depicts of what
happened in this game in pretty much in
10 seconds so here it is I hope you guys
enjoy it let's let's check it out so
this is one of their clashes it was some
three or four years ago with Queen and
of course with this is how close the the
chess catwalk check this out
easy baby yeah so there we have it
really really close but in the end
voyboy prevailed sir and also I that's
why I use that for the title of the
video yeah I do hope you enjoyed it I
would like to thank victory investments
Tanner Olivia Mohammed Omri Marion sin
OSA and Mark Matz and for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the POC
champs we will probably cover the final
match of course continuing the Paul
Morphy saga checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world and do join
the arena today it is Friday so as usual
we will have an Ice Arena unleashes so
see you soon guys and thanks a lot